البيان الختامي للقمه العربيه في جده يؤكد
ضروره حل الازمات في الدول العربيه عربيا
ويرفض التدخلات الخارجيه
نعمل على مساعده اطراف اليمنيه للوصول الى
حل سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمني وفيما
يخص السودان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس للحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
مقدراته وفي هذا الصدد الامير محمد بن
سلمان يؤكد في قمه جده استمرار جهود
المملكه لحل ازمتي السودان واليمن
اشاركوا في قمه السبع باليابان وبايدن
يؤكد موافقته على تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على اف 16
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الانباء من العربيه
جدد الزعماء العرب في اعلان الجده في ختام
اعمال القمه العربيه في السعوديه التاكيد
على مركزيه القضيه الفلسطينيه كاحد
العوامل الرئيسيه لاستقرار المنطقه واهميه
تكثيف الجهود للتوصل الى تسويه شامله
وعادله للقضيه ودعاء اعلانه جده الى
التهدئه في السودان وتغليب لغه الحوار
والحفاظ على المؤسسات الوطنيه في البلاد
ورفض اي تدخل خارجي من شانه تاجيج الصراع
اعلان ضد شدد على اهميه مواصله وتكثيف
الجهود العربيه الراميه الى مساعده سوريا
للتجاوز ازمتها كما اكد على دعم الجهود
الامميه والاقليميه للتوصل الى حل سياسي
شامل للازمه اليمنيه وابدا بيان جده تضامن
التام مع لبنان كما دعا الى انتخاب رئيس
جمهوريه يرضي طموحات اللبنانيين
وشدد الاعلان على وقف التدخلات الخارجيه
في شؤون الداخليه للدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعلان جده اهميه تكثيف الجهود للتوصل الى
تسويه شامله وعادله للقضيه الفلسطينيه
ضروره التهدئه وتغيب لغه الحوار والحفاظ
على المؤسسات الوطنيه في السودان اهميه
مواصله وتكثيف الجهود العربيه الراميه الى
مساعده سوريا لتجاوز ازمتها دعم الجهود
الامميه والاقليميه للتوصل الى حل سياسي
شامل للازمه اليمنيه التضامن التام مع
لبنان والدعوه الى انتخاب رئيس جمهوريه
يرضي طموحات اللبنانيين التشديد على وقف
التدخلات الخارجيه في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول العربيه
التنميه المستدامه والامن والاستقرار
والعيش في سلام حق اصيل للمواطن العربي
اهميه استثمار الموارد والفرص والامكانات
لتحقيق نهضه عربيه صناعيه وزراعيه شامله
الالتزام بقيم الحوار والتسامح وعدم
التدخل في شؤون الاخرين تحت اي ذريعه
المحافظه على الثقافه والهويه العربيه
الاصيله وابراز الموروث الحضاري والفكري
الاشاده بحرص السعوديه على توفير الظروف
الملائمه لتحقيق الاستقرار والنمو
الاقتصادي مبادره انشاء حاويه فكريه
للبحوث والدراسات في الاستدامه والتنميه
الاقتصاديه
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
اكد خلال كلمته في القمه العربيه الثانيه
والثلاثين في جده على ان السعوديه لن تسمح
بان تكون المنطقه ميدانا للصراعات كما شدد
على ضروره المضي في السلام والبناء
والتعاون نؤكد لدول الجوار والاصدقاء في
الغرب والشرق ان الماضون للسلام والخير
والتعاون والبناء بما يحقق مصالح شعوبنا
ويصون حقوق امتنا واننا لن نسمح منطقتنا
ميدان للصراعات
ان شقاق المملكه العربيه السعوديه يكرسون
جهودهم في دعم القضايا العربيه كما نعمل
على مساعده اطراف اليمنيه للوصول الى حل
سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمني وفيما يخص
السودان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس للحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
مقدراته وفي هذا الصدق فلم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ترحب بتوقيع طرفي نزاع
على اعلان جده الالتزام بحمايه مدنيين
وتسهيل العمل الانساني ونامل التركيز خلال
هذه المحادثات على وقف فعال لاطلاق النار
محمد بن سلمان اجتمع مع الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد على هامش القمه العربيه في جده
وجرى خلال اللقاء استعراض سبل تعزيز
العلاقات بين البلدين الى جانب بحث عدد من
المسائل ذات الاهتمام المشترك والجهود
المبذوله بشانها
الرئيس سوري بشر الاسد قال خلال كلمه الله
في القمه العربيه في جده ان بلاده امام
فرصه تاريخيه لاعاده ترتيب اوضاعه بعيدا
عن التدخل الاجنبي واضح ان ذلك يتطلب
اعاده موضع سوريا كجزء فاعل هي فرصه
تاريخيه لاعاده ترتيب شؤوننا باقل قدر من
التدخل الاجنبي وهو ما يتطلب اعاده
موضوعنا في هذا العالم الذي يتكون اليوم
كي نكون جزءا فاعلا فيه مستثمرين في
الاجواء الايجابيه الناشئه عن المصالحات
التي سبقت القمه وصولا اليها اليوم
قال رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسيه اليماني
رشاد العليمي ان بلاده تترقب ثمار المساعي
الحديثه التي تقودها السعوديه وعمان
لاحياء الهدنه التي التزمت بها الحكومه من
طرف واحد حرصا على انهاء معاناه اليمني
وها نحن اليوم من جديد نترقب ثمار المساعي
الحديثه التي يقودها الاشقاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وسلطنه عمان لاحياء ذات
الهدنه التي التزمنا باستمرارها من طرف
واحد حرصا على انهاء معاناه شعبنا وتفويت
اي فرصه للمليشيات في العوده الى التصعيد
الشامل
وبدلا من ابداء حسن النوايا تجاه
المبادرات الحكوميه تواصل تلك الميليشيات
للشهر الثامن على التوالي منعا وصول السفن
والناقلات التجاريه الى موانئنا سعيا منها
لسحق المكاسب المحققه في المحافظات
المحرره بما في ذلك انتظام دفع مروات
الموظفين واعاقه فرص توسيعها لتشمل
الموظفين في المناطق الخاضعه بالقوه
لسيطره الميليشيات
وفي لقاء الله على هامش القمه العربيه في
جده اشاد رئيس الوزراء اللبناني نجيب
ميقاتي بمخرجات اعمال القمه فقال انها
تهدف الى تصفيه المشاكل العربيه وصولا الى
نقطه صقر يعني بدايه القمه القمه التعقس
تماما تصفير المشاكل في المنطقه
فالسياسه المتبعه اليوم في المنطقه هي 0
مشاكل مع دول الجوار ومع الدول العربيه
بشكل عام فانعكست حتما بخلال هذه القمه
بمسار هذه القمه خلال مناقشات التي القيت
في القمه
المقارنات بالاجماع دون اي تحفظ اعلان جده
بدون اي تحفظ كل هذه الامور تعني باذن
الله ان الامور سياره بالطريق الصحيح
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه بن فرحان ان
المملكه تعمل مع واشنطن للوصول الى هدنه
انسانيه في السودان داعيا الاطراف
السودانيه الى التحلي بالمسؤوليه واللجوء
للحوار طبعا نعمل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
بالتعامل مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حاليا على تهيئه الاجواء للوصول الى هدنه
انسانيه بعد ان صدر اعلان جدا التزامات
بالمبادئ الانسانيه والان نطمح ان نصل
قريبا ان شاء الله الى هذه الهدنه وهذه
الهدنه تاسس لما ياتي من بعدها من حوار
نامل من خلال الوصول الى حل لهذا النزال
لكن التركيز الان هو على الوصول الى هدنه
انسانيه تتيح للمواطنين السودانيين يعني
التنفس قليلا ويعني ان يصلوني لحاجاتهم
الانسانيه المباشره الوضع في الخرطومه
مناطق في السودان الحقيقه مؤسف للغايه
ولذلك من المهم ان نصل الان الى هذه
الهدنه ومن هذا المنبر ادعو الجميع
الاطراف في السودان الى
التحرير المسؤوليه والجنوح الى الحوار
والابتعاد عن استخدام السلاح لحل الخلافات
اكد ممثله السودان دفع الله الحاج في قمه
جده على انه اذا تخلت قوات الدعم السريع
عن سلاحها سيتم العفو عنها مشددا على ان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه قادره بكفاءتها
على هزيمه قوه الدعم
نحن في حكومه السودان لسنا دعاه حرب لكنها
فرضت علينا واذا ما جنحت القوات المتمرده
للسلم سنجنح
له واذا وضعوا السلاح سيتم العفو عنهم بل
وان ابواب القوه القوات المسلحه السودانيه
مشرعه لدمجهم ان رغبوا ولكن في ذات الوقت
اؤكد لكم ان القوات المسلحه السودانيه بما
عرف عنها عبر عقود من الزمان من كفاءه
واقدام وشجاعه ومهنيه عاليه
قادره على هزيمه التمرد فلا مجال للتشكيك
فيها
وفي السودان صدر مرسوم دستوري باعفاء قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو حميد
تيم من منصبه
كنبريسياده وصل قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان رئيس المجلس مرسوما بتعيين
مالك عقار نائبه لرئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني كما اكد البرشوم الدستوري دخوله
حيز التنفيذ من تاريخ اصداره
مرسوم دستوري في السودان
يقصي اشخاصا ويعين اخرين
البرهان يعرف يحميتي من منصب نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده
ويصدر قرارا بتعيين ملك عقار خلفا له
ليصبح عقار نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني البرهان ايضا كلف الفريق اول ركن
شمس الدين كباشي
بمنصب نائب القائد العام للجيش
كما عين البرهان الفريق اول ياسر العطا
مساعدا للقائد العام للقوه المسلحه
[موسيقى]
خلف اللحميتي من هو مالك عقار كلف البرهان
مالك عجار نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده مالك
عكار عمل بالتدريس في بدايه حياته ابريل
2010 انتخب حاكما لولايه النيل الازرق
فبراير 2011 اصبح رئيسا للحركه الشعبيه في
القطاع الشمالي الثالث من سبتمبر 2011 عزل
مالك عجار من منصبه كحاكم لولايه النيل
الازرق بعد مواجهات مع الجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الرئيس التركيه يلتقي المرشح الخاسر سنان
اوغان ويؤكد رفضه دعوات المعارضه للترحيل
شامل للاجئ
اهلا بكم مجددا الى نشره لعامله من
العربيه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه اليابانيه ان الرئيس
الاوكراني ولد امير جلنسكي سيحضروا قمه
مجموعه السبعه في مدينه هيروشيما
اليابانيه وفي تحول كبير في الدعم الغربي
قال مسؤولون امريكي في البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس جو بايدن الذي يشارك في قمه مجموعه
سبع في اليابان اكد لمحاوريه دعمه مبادره
مشتركه تهدف الى تدريب الطيارين اوكرانيين
على طائرات مقاتله من الجيل الرابع بما
يشمل مقاتلات اف 16
لطالما لاعبه الاسلحه الغربيه دورا مهما
في تحويل ساحه المعارك باوكرانيا لكن ثمه
اسلحه احتجت كييف الى ضغط كبير وطويل حتى
حصلت عليه منها الدبابات الغربيه
كالالمانيه من طراز ليوبارد وابرانز
الامريكيه وتشالنجر البريطانيه
ساعات الى صواريخ بعيده المدى تقول لندن
انها تزود اوكرانيا بصواريخ من طراز ستوم
شادو مداها يبلغ اكثر من 250 كيلومترا لكن
تمت ما تسعى اليه اوكرانيا ايضا مقاتله
طالما رفضت واشنطن تسليمها لاوكرانيا باتت
كييف اقرب الى تسلمها لكن من طرف ثالث
المقاتله اف 16 او الصقر المهاجم طائره
مقاتله تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت مثاليه في
تنفيذ الهجمات جوجو وجو ارض لهذه المقاتله
القدره على التحليق على ارتفاعات مختلفه
ويمكنها التحليق لاكثر من 860 كيلومترا
قبل العوده لقعدتها بتسارع 9 جي اي بتسعه
اضعاف قوه الجاذبيه وهو ما يتجاوز قدرات
الطائرات المقاتله قادره على رصد اهدافها
بدقه في جميع الظروف الجويه كما تكشف
الطائرات التي تحلق على دفاع منخفض يمكنها
اصابه اهدافها بدقه والدفاع عن نفسها ضد
الطائرات المعاديه قمره القياده للطيار
توفر رؤيه خاليه من اي نقاط عمياء الطائره
مزوده بانظمه متقدمه بتحديد المواقع
الجغرافيه وانظمه ملاحه جويه ومعلومات
توجيهيه للطيار وانظمه اتصالات راديويه
متقدمه هذه المقاتله تريدها كييف لتعزيز
قدراتها على اسقاط الصواريخ التي تطلقها
المقاتله الروسيه كما يمكنها ان تكون
عاملا رادعا لاوكرانيا ضد القوات الجويه
الروسيه
ارسال هذه المقاتله يثير مخاوف مسؤولين
امريكيين فتزويد كييف بها يعني تقليصا
لتمويل احتياجات كييف الدفاعيه الاخرى
لفتره الحاليه اضافه الى اشهر من التدريب
للطيارين الاوكرانيين عليها
الاف سته عشر ستساهم في تغيير موازين
القوه والمعادله العسكريه على الارض كما
فعلت اسلحه غربيه وصلت ميادين المعارك
سابقا
وفي تطورات الميدانيه للحرب في اوكرانيا
فادت وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه بسماع دوي
انفجارات في العاصمه الاوكرانيه وسقوط
حطام وسيارات على عدد من الشوارع في كييف
كما قالت مصادر اوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه عززت مواقعها الدفاعيه داخل وفي
محيط محطه نوويه جنوب البلاد وبحسب شهود
العيان فان الروس حفروا خنادق حول المدينه
وزرعوا مزيدا من الالغام في مدينه
انرهودار وقاموا مواقع الاطلاق النار فوق
مباني بارزه في المدينه من جهته قدر بترو
كوتين رئيس شركه انر غواتوم ان عدد القوات
الروسيه من المصنع او في المصنع قد زاد من
حوالي 500 الى 1500 مقاتل فلاشر الاخيره
واضاف انه يعتقد انهم اجروا بالفعل
تدريبات في المنشاه للتمرن على الانسحاب
خاصه وان الروس لديهم طريق داد رئيسي واحد
للمحطه النوويه يربطهم بجزيره القرم وفي
حال انقطاعه
ستضطر موسكو الى التراجع
وبخصوص قال قائد القوات باجنر الروسيه
افقيني بروجين ان رجاله على وشك استكمال
الاستيلاء على المدينه مشيرا الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر على 600 متر مربع
فقط منه
المعارك الدمويه العنيفه مستمره في مخموت
تقدمت وحدات فاجنر 500 متر واصبحت تسيطر
على مساحه تصل الى ثلاثه الاف وثلاث مئه
متر مربع وباتت القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر
على 600 متر مربع فقط ونحن على وشك
الانتهاء من المهمه والعدو يقوم باستدعاء
قوات احتياطيه
حضر الكرمل من تلاشي اخر ضوابط المتبقيه
من معاهده تخفيض الاسلحه بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا المعروفه
بعدما قدمت الولايات المتحده مشروع قانون
لالغاء اتفاقيه ستارت الجديده بشان
الاسلحه النوويه
اعلنت واشنطن فرض عقوبات جديده على
الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه وادراج 49
فردا على قائمه العقوبات وبحسب بيان وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه طالت العقوبات مسئولين
بارزين من بينهم نائبه رئيس الوزراء
الروسي واحد موسى الرئيس ووزيره التربيه
كذلك طالت العقوبات شركات الروسيه تعمل في
مجال النفط ورد على ذلك اعلنت روسيا حضرت
دخول 500 امريكي الى اراضيها من بينهم
رئيس الامريكي السابق باراك اوباما
استانفت رحلات الجويه بين روسيا وجورجيا
بعد انقطاع عندما لاربع سنوات وذلك بعد ان
رفع الرئيس الروسي
قرار الحظر الاحادي على الطيران الجورجي
الصادر عام 2019
لاغيا نظام التاشيره لدخول الجورجيين
وكاله روسيا نقلا عن قاعده بيانات وزاره
الداخليه الروسيه باصدار مذكره اعتقال بحق
قاضي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه الذي امر
باعتقال بوتين وذلك بعد ان اصبح الرئيس
الروسي ثاني رئيس تصدق بحقه مذكره اعتقال
وهو على راس السلطه مطلوبا للعداله
الدوليه بدعوى ارتكابه جرائم حرب وبامر من
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوريه
ذكرت مسوده لبيان قمه مجموعه السبع اطلاط
عليها
ان زعماء المجموعه لا يزالون قلقين بشده
ازاله مضي ايران قدما في البرنامج النووي
مؤكدين عزمهم ان لا تطور ايران سلاحا
نوويا لما يشكله من تهديد وزعزعه لاستقرار
المنطقه بما في ذلك نقل الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره والتقنيات ذات الصله
الى جهات حكوميه وغير حكوميه كما اعرب
قاده مجموعه السبع عن قلقهم من تسارع بناء
الصين لترسالتها النوويه لما يشكله من خطر
للاستقرار العالمي والاقليمي مشددين على
ضروره التصدي للتحركات الصينيه
الصين هاجس الدول الغربيه والعنصر الرئيسي
في قممها السياسيه وهذا حال قمه السبع في
هيروشيما
التحركات الصينيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
ومحاولتها فرض سيطرتها على هذا الممر
البحري من خلال ضم جزر تطالب بها دول جنوب
شرق اسيا اضافه الى مناوراتها العسكريه
التي تقترب من شواطئ تايوان مره بعد
الاخرى هي مصدر قلق لدول المجموعه وعلى
راسها امريكا التي تدعم مانيلا عسكريا
لتامين حدودها
اما على المستوى الاقتصادي في الاشهر التي
سبقت القمه قامت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والاتحاد الاوروبي واليابان
بتنسيق سياسه تستبعد الفصل الكامل للتجاره
مع بكين اكبر اقتصاد في اسيا فالصين هي
الشريك الاقتصادي الاول لليابان والاتحاد
الاوروبي
والثالث للولايات المتحده بعد كندا
والمكسيك ولهذا يصعب القطع الكامل معها
ولكن يبقى من غير الواضح الى اي مدى قد
تكون اليابان والاوروبيون على استعداد
لاتخاذ اجراءات يمكن ان تستفز بكين نظرا
لما يمكن ان تتخذه هذه الاخيره من اجراءات
انتقاميه
الصين سبقت قمه السبع ونظمت قمه استضافت
فيها كازاخستان وقرغيزيستان وطاجيكستان
وكذلك تركمانستان واوزباكستان وهذا
استمرار في مسعا لتوسيع نطاق تاثيرها
اسيويا بعيدا عن الضغوطات الغربيه
رفض الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
مقابله مع شبكات سين ان قبل جوله الاعاده
للانتخابات الرئاسيه رفضا لدعان لمطالب
المرشح سابق للرئاسه سنان اوغان ورفض
اردوغان واعتبره انحناء لرغبات اوجان
مشيرا الى انه شخص لا يحب التفاوض بهذه
الطريقه وقال اردوغان ان ناخبين هم من
يصنعون الملوك وكان اردوغان قد اجتمع بشكل
مفاجئ في مكتب الاخير باسطنبول كما رفض
اردوغان دعوات المعارضه للترحيل الشامل
للاجئين وحول روسيا قال اردوغان ان تركيا
تتمتع بعلاقه خاصه ومتناميه مع رئيس روسيا
فلاديمير بوتين وقال ان بلاده ليست ملزمه
بالعقوبات الغربيه على موسكو واضاف ان
روسيا وتركيا بحاجه الى بعضهم البعض في كل
مجال ممكن
فالختام هذا تذكير بابرز العناو
البيان الختامي للقمه العربيه في جده يؤكد
ضروره حل الازمات في الدول العربيه عربيه
عربيه ويرفض التدخلات الخارجيه
نعمل على مساعده اطراف اليمنيه للوصول الى
حل سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمنيه وفيما
يخص السودان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس للحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
المخدراته وفي هذا الصدد الامير محمد بن
سلمان يؤكده في قمه جده استمرار جهود
المملكه لحل ازمتي السودان والياس
ومجموعه سبع تنتظر في اليابان يؤكد
موافقته على تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على اف 16
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات